it all started as I was hunting for a
chat gpt-like model that was open
sourced of good quality and locally
runnable on a single consumer GPU so
ideally under 24 gigabytes of memory I
came across things like GPT for all in
together computers 20 Bill and seven
Bill chat models based on a Luther ai's
Neo X models and others like pythia but
then I stumbled upon chat glm 6B a
relatively tiny model capable of running
on as little as six gigabytes of memory
at int4 with quantization or 13
gigabytes at half Precision for
inference not only is this model
extremely small it's quite effective at
just single query and response as well
as multiple back and forths with some
decently sized contacts it's definitely
not a full chat GPT but it's shockingly
good for its size for example we can
just ask it to do a typical
summarization task and then we can ask
it to instead condense that down to a
single sentence this not only
exemplifies a bit of context from chat
history and using it and being smart in
sort of like this kind of back and forth
chat context but it's also got a pretty
good understanding of the important
elements both in the longer
summarization giving us the bits that
actually mattered as well as being able
to drop the entire article down to a
single sentence pretty well at this
point I think most of you guys are
pretty familiar with the things that
large language models can do so I'm just
not going to go through everything in
the video just showing you a bunch of
examples that you've probably seen many
times with many different models but
there are quite quite a few pitfalls
that smaller models usually have first a
long enough chat context will begin to
confuse the model and smaller models
tend to just plain make mistakes way
more often way more quickly or even
almost always if you don't fine tune
them or restrict them in some way with
like pre-prompting and or like even
fine-tuning via training but chat glm 6B
was surprisingly good comparatively to
other models of similar size and even a
little bigger maybe to 10 or 20 billion
even and it was good like right out of
the box so I dug a tiny bit because up
to this point I had never even
personally heard of this glm doing a
Google search or even a chat GPT search
it tells me that glm stands for
generalized linear model and I was
pretty confident that this was not what
the glm stood for in this specific
context so first I found the original
glm paper from the 17th of March 2022
which defines glm as a general language
model now from my very brief
understanding and first read through it
does seem as though a glm is still a
generative pre-trained Transformer model
but the glm does seem to be
differentiated by bi-directional
attention as compared to unidirectional
attention that most other GPT models use
as well as the use of the gaussian error
linear unit
instead of the traditional rectified
linear unit or relio the difference of
these activation functions is extremely
obvious upon graphing the gel U gel you
I'm not really sure I'm going to I guess
I'll say gel you is a smoother function
with a non-zero derivative for all the
inputs it's slightly more complicated to
actually calculate as shown here in the
code which also makes it a bit more
computationally intense so to speak but
the authors of the glm paper argue that
it is worth the trade-off and that the
trade-off is essentially negligible when
scaled out to these large language
models anyways in general some research
has also suggested that the gel U is
also it's just more useful for very
large and deep neural networks which
suffer from issues like Vanishing
gradients so from here the glm-130b
paper or 130 billion parameters paper
can be found from the 5th of October
2022. I'll link both of these papers in
the description by the way if I forget
someone just remind me and I'll put them
in now this is the first open source
large-scale implementation of a glm that
I could find and again it does seem as
though even this glm is very structured
very similar to gpt3 and that the main
differentiator here is going to be that
gel U activation function in the
bi-directional attention so this is this
glm 130 billion parameter model is meant
to be comparable to gpd3 which has 175
billion parameters but the goal was to
make this comparable model capable of
running on much more consumer like
Hardware so in this case glm-130b
through infor with quantization can run
on as minimal as four 30 90s to put this
in perspective gpt3 for inference is
going to want something like a 150 000
machine or more whereas glm-130b is
going to want something more like a 30
to 40 000 machine now I know you if you
go into like the used Market or you
might be able to get deals in other ways
and finagle even less money but at the
end of the day it's like a fifth of the
cost so um this is a pretty substantial
difference on what will be the End
Hardware to run inference with these
models what will be the requirement and
this is just a staggering difference
we can also compare glm-130b to models
like opt and Bloom and at least given
the benchmarks that the authors have
provided it does appear that glm-130b is
extremely competitive at generative
tasks natural language understanding
tasks and multilingual tasks noting that
glm-130b is a mixed model of both
English and Chinese although I would say
it seems to be more favoring towards
Chinese but it's a little unclear to me
the data that's used at least in glm
130b will get to glm chat glm 6B in a
moment again I will link both the
original glm paper as well as the
glm-130b paper as both of these actually
have some pretty interesting insights
but the glm-130b paper also goes into
some more depth and detail about
training very large models especially
when compared to more medium-sized
models like 10 billion parameters or
less versus you know what does it take
to do a 100 billion parameter model also
one of the other insights that they
brought up which I have kind of out this
way for a while I haven't seen it in the
research but apparently this is a thing
that there seems to be a large amount of
people that seem to think that these
very very large models are all almost
across the board suffering from not
being fully trained in my opinion the
first model that I really felt this way
on was and is the bloom 176 billion
parameter model if you look at the
tensorboard graph it just is it's very
obvious when you look at it that
training did not finish like they just
didn't finish training it and like all
these other models including the 130
Bill model
especially if you want to open source
these models or share them with the
world you need grants you need somebody
to sponsor this and you usually only get
a certain fixed period of time to get it
done and given all the other hardships
that you're going to come across as you
try to do this it just happens to be the
case more often than not that these
models just probably aren't actually
even being fully trained now this all
brings us to chat glm 6B which is 6
billion parameter which as of yet no
paper is offered that I can find yet but
there is a blog post with some useful
ish information once you convert it from
Chinese to English but I do hope they
release a paper eventually here too on
what did they do did they do anything
really different RL rlhf wise so
reinforcement learning through human
feedback wise but mainly though chat glm
has 6.2 billion parameters a context
length in training of 2048 and is
intended to run on as minimal as a
single 2080 TI I can also see that
there's a chat glm main model so a
full-sized chat glm with 100 billion
parameters but this one doesn't appear
to be open sourced yet and is being
slowly rolled out to researchers and
it's a little unclear to me if they ever
intend to release the full-size chat glm
but we'll see so I cannot test this but
the authors note that chat glm is most
successful with with Chinese dialogue
obviously I can't actually test this and
I believe this is true with chat glm the
full size and Chad glm 6B I can only
test on English
and this isn't really super shocking
given that the research is mainly from a
group at a Chinese University that said
getting back to where all this began for
me personally is I find that the chat
glm 6B model is just the best for this
kind of like use 10-ish billion
parameter model size but even compared
to some of the 20 billion parameter
models I find chat glm 6B to be just
generally better now I think both all of
this requires much more time to kind of
dive in and kind of poke around and see
or maybe figure out what's the best way
to sort of prompt some of these smaller
models it might just be the case that
the way I'm used to prompting models
just happens to work better with chat
glm6b but I just can't help but feel
like man this is a really cool model
it's really fast and it's really small
that memory footprint it is exceptional
and then from there it is a bit unclear
to me at this point if this sort of all
of these successes has more to do with
say the glm attributes of the
bi-directional attention or the gel U
activation function or possibly is it
the multi-task training that they did so
again uh at least with the glm models
for the 130b billion parameter model
they did things like text generation but
then also specific tasks uh I think it
was like five percent or something was
like more specific masking tasks so it's
curious if maybe that has to has some
sort of roll into it uh also this is one
of the I think few ish models where you
have a very uh very large body of text
of both Chinese and English and we do
have lots of multilingual models but
those multilingual models tend to suffer
pretty substantially on something like
Chinese because Chinese is such a vastly
different language than something like
English and the difference between
Chinese and English is going to be just
huge compared to maybe English and I
don't know Spanish or something like
that the differences are so staggering
that you might even say that this is
more of a multi-modal model or for sure
like a multi-task type model and we've
already seen that these doing that sort
of thing to these models you would have
thought that oh for any specific task it
would be better to just make it you know
train a model to do that specific task
and you'll have the most success that
way but that is proving to be very false
especially as we make models bigger and
bigger it does seem like multitask
multimodal all this stuff seems to
benefit even those singular tasks that
they might do so getting back to how I
got here in the first place to use this
model it's exceptionally simple to
actually get going I'm going to link the
hugging face space for The Unofficial
demo in the description so you can
really just you can just go there and
play with it in your browser see if it
works for maybe some of your ideas but
you can also copy that code and run that
demo completely locally download the
actual model the way it's all that you
could fine tune it from here if you
wanted you can also just run it
headlessly you don't have to run it
through this radio app or you don't have
to make a chat app out of it you can
make it do other things maybe you want
to make an app that summarizes text for
example so you could really just do
whatever the heck you want with it so
anyways that was a pretty interesting
Journey going through all this stuff in
the glm and I'm curious to see if glm is
going to just simply Encompass the
Chinese variants of these essentially
GPT style models or will we start seeing
much more of this bi-directional
attention going on as well as the Glu
activation function you know who knows
like the gpt4 could have been using gel
you we just we don't know anything
because open AI is no not being open
about uh gpt4 the other thing that I
really appreciate here is it is clear
that through all of these models the
researchers aren't just thinking like
okay let's make a bigger model or okay
let's make a model that does this and
let's just you know pick some arbitrary
size
they went into this thinking about okay
well chat glm 6B for example we want to
be able to fit this on a 2080 TI I think
it was a 2080 TI or a 2080 but whatever
the case 6 billion or six gigs of memory
same thing with uh glm 130b we want to
be able to run this on consumer Hardware
so for on a 4 30 90 setup
um if you could call that consumer but
it's at least work you know consumer
workstation let's say you didn't need to
buy uh v100s a100s RTX 8000s you didn't
have to buy any of these like server
grade cards and pay that server grade
price and that is the difference between
um uh that that is that like 5x markup
like the server grade cards are just so
much more expensive I at least
personally hope that as time goes on
researchers more and more continue
thinking about things in terms of okay
well what would be the hardware
requirements of this who could run it
what size should we go with you know
start thinking in that way more often
because sometimes times it does seem
like these models are just arbitrarily
sized I also really appreciate the
breakdown of the major issues that the
researchers encountered in the training
of
glm-130b in this like technical report
section of their paper they basically go
through and kind of like outline some of
the major uh issues like unforeseen
issues that they came across as they
tried to train one of these very very
large models anyways that's chat glm 6B
definitely a cool model to check out
again links to everything will be in the
description and even if you don't have a
GPU to run this on you can still play
with it in your browser and it's
definitely worth checking out this like
arguably very tiny model that is really
good so all that said there are still
quite a few models coming soon and
there's probably going to be a lot of
competition in the space going forward
and even some of the existing models uh
like from a Luther Ai and to you know
together computer and some of these
others are still in like active training
and they're getting like updates and
stuff so there's definitely going to be
a lot of compensation in the space going
forward and I'm I'm super excited to
kind of see what other people come up
with as time goes on I'd also like to
take another pass at even like the the
pythia for example a variance from a
Luther Ai and the chat variants from
together computer which those seem to be
very intertwined I need to like do a
little more research into those and
figure out like who played what role but
it seems like those are all based on
these like Neo X or gptj and those kinds
of models so it's like it seems like a
Luther Ai and together computer are kind
of teaming up to make these chat uh
variants but at least again
in my short experience and experiments
um I would say that chat glm 6B is the
best small chat style GPT chat GPT like
model that you can run locally on as
little as six uh six gigabytes of memory
so that's all for now if you're looking
to learn more about neural networks and
how they work you can check out the
neural networks from scratchbook at
nnfs.io otherwise I will see you all in
another video and also if you have a
chat uh things that you want me to look
at if you think I didn't do something
Justice or you disagree or whatever feel
free to comment below I'm curious to see
what what you guys are thinking so
there's a lot of these things I look
into and like people are saying one
thing and then as soon as I voice my
opinion like I'm like I actually don't
really like this or I think this one's
really cool and I find out like the
public sentiment or just like the
sentiment people have does seem to vary
greatly and um it's interesting to hear
what other people are thinking and
feeling and finding and all that so
anyways that's all for now I will see
you all in another video